continues we'll get to weather in a
moment but we're going to talk about
something very festive and holiday-ish i
know and it certainly doesn't feel like
it but it looks like christmas came
early because we're at glittering lights
this morning it's the holiday favorite
it is back here at the speedway
officially opening today after that soft
opening last night hector is there live
reporting for us this morning he's got a
santa hat on and boy what's the latest
this year did they add another million
lights hector
possibly a few million more lights good
morning guys so i don't know about you
guys but i could show you some holiday
cheer after this year so take a look
right behind me if you look closely and
if you squint you can see the las vegas
strip right behind those uh lit up teddy
bears that are bouncing off and just
moving across here joining us live this
morning we have john bentham to talk to
us about what's new this year good
morning to you sir and uh thanks for
having us again great to see you again
good morning hector and happy holidays
happy early holidays that's right it's
great to be it's great to say that we
actually hosted a few thousand vets and
their families last night it was really
fun to see their faces light up and just
say happy holidays again that's great to
hear and coming up too this monday will
be what it's our military monday
appreciation night and all military
active and inactive are welcome to come
their families everybody in the car will
get in for free all right so 5 million
lights i imagine a lot of challenges go
with putting that on it there was a lot
of challenges especially this year um
but we're glad that we're we were able
to construct it all put it all up and
we're ready tell us how the shipping
delays at the docks kind of slowed you
guys down and really uh slowed some
product yeah really for our equipment
our big equipment to put up all these
arches it takes us some lifts and they
couldn't get replacement parts to get
those fixed why
you know
you got me
well tell us about you know what
visitors can expect tickets start at 25
going strong for 21 long years that's
right tickets are 25 per car load so
it's a great deal you don't have to mess
with strollers or with jackets or you
can stay right and enjoy the the light
show from the comfort warmth of your car
tickets as you said start at 25 but if
you bring a bag of gently used household
goods for goodwill of southern nevada
will give you five dollars off right at
the gate so you could get in for as low
as 20 that's a great deal it is so how
many people can you pack in your car you
know what we've had people pack all the
way from 20 to 30 that the types of
creativity that people have last night
we had people with trailers there's a
family that always comes in a pontoon
boat so there's lots of fun things and
you know being next to nellis we uh you
can hear the jets right now that's
really cool probably look right there
they're doing right behind you they're
doing this for you right now heather and
sherry
so that's really cool and uh tell us
about the area we're in just one of many
two and a half miles yeah we've got two
and a half miles full of five million
led lights we've got over a thousand
display areas this elements this year
and yeah you drive up here you've got
elves throwing teddy bears into
stockings followed by candy cane arches
snowflake arches and then all the way
light bulb arches into our dinosaur land
and also the military fighter jets right
behind us they're doing that just for us
at channel 8.
that's fantastic
lastly you guys uh it also helps
organizations locally lastly every every
ticket sold goes to speedway children's
charities a portion of tickets go to
speed rachel charities which gathers
money all year long and then we
distribute it through a grant process to
last year was a 55 different children's
charities but the best news is right
here in southern nevada right in our
community thank you so much so we have
another area to show you that's still
ahead at 6 30 for now reporting live
hector mejia back to you guys happy
early holidays
happy holidays
if they had come back on them they'd fit
right in the theme
thank you hector wow that is beautiful
it does put you in the spirit it does
and i think john and we were talking
earlier that if you look really hard
somewhere out there you might see a
leftover glow stick from edc
i think